- [Mark] All right Ke, welcome back.
- [Ke] Thank you for having me back.
- So it hasn't been that
long since we spoke,
it was like a month or so.
- [Ke] Maybe two weeks.
- [Mark] Only two weeks?
- [Ke] Yeah
(Mark mumbles)
- [Mark] But how have things
been since I posted your video?
- Actually, they've
been kinda good and bad.
The good part, let's start with the good
because the good is always
the greatest part of it all.
So the good part about
it is I did what I said
I wanted to do.
I said, I wanted to be the
parent that made it back
and I made it back.
I've currently been living
in a home with my children,
all three of them.
- [Mark] You are in Carson?
- Yes in Carson.
- I was able..
- [Mark] Far from Skid Row.
- Very far from skid row (laughing)
I was able to set aside some
differences with family members
that worked things out for my better
to where I was able to
get back to my kids.
But it was a battle to get there.
Before I got there,
I actually had to reach my breaking point.
What I mean by that is, I went
through a couple of obstacles
that kinda slowed me down.
And me trying to figure out
if I'm supposed to stay here
or if I'm supposed to go,
like this life is not meant
for you to get content
and stuck and stagnated.
Well, I got stuck. I got comfortable.
And I couldn't get the
wake up call that I needed
so it took something a
little bit more severe
for me to actually wake up.
The guy that I spoke about
in the first interview
I tried so hard to build
with this person, right?
So this man brutally attacked me.
When I say from six and
Sanford, this man attacked me
where I was barely able
to escape with my life.
I was so in fear, everybody in the hotel
or whatever you wanna call it, the SRO.
I cried for help, no one came for help.
These people actually sat by
and watched this man abuse me
and could not give a lending hand
because they are so in fear
or they feel like it's not their business.
Things like this are not right.
This man stopped and
forced me to walk with him
to the store on Wall.
Is that Wall?
No, San Pedro in Seventh Street
which is the Green Apple, right?
Inside this store this man
continued to brutally attack me.
And all the people in the store had to say
was can you please leave the store?
I'm begging this woman.
I had a seizure the other
day ma'am can you help me?
I'm pregnant, like this man
is sucking me in my hand,
he's doing all this stuff
to me and no one cared.
I felt so bad cause like is
this really what the world
has come to?
When we see people going through stuff
and we cannot stop just
to lend a helping hand.
So immediately I called my mother-in-law
who is my children's grandmother.
And I explained the story to her
and she asked me, she said, are you ready?
Are you truly ready?
And at that moment I knew what she meant.
Yes, I'm ready.
I will leave all of this stuff behind
just to have that moment with my children.
Barely escaping downtown with my life,
I was just so excited
to get back to my kids
that I didn't care that I
didn't have a pot to piss in,
I didn't have a dollar
to spend on anything.
Just being reunited with my babies
made everything worth my while.
I was so excited.
And I really pray that whatever it is
that this guy is going
through, he gets through it.
Like, no one in this world
should be left alone.
- [Mark] And what are you
gonna about with the baby?
- I'm gonna continue to go
through with my pregnancy.
I'm gonna take care of my child
just like I take care of the
rest of my other children
and we're gonna grow from
it and that's all we can do.
I've reached my downfall.
I hit my rock bottom.
I got my wake up.
Unfortunately, a lot of
people are not blessed
to get that wake up call
to where they're like,
okay well I really need
to make this change now
before something bad happens.
I was able to.
And with no hesitation, I took it and ran.
- [Mark] Do you miss anything
about the past lifestyle
that you had?
I assume you've given up drugs too?
- No, I don't miss getting high.
The only thing I would say that I miss
is some of the good people
that I met down here.
That's it.
- [Mark] Are you talking
about here or Figueroa Street?
- Here, Skid Row.
- [Mark] Okay, cause you
were only in Skid Row
for a short time.
- Yeah, but I met some
beautiful people here.
- [Mark] Yeah there're
some cool people here.
- Like some that gave me
food when I didn't have it,
clothes, a place to stay, all
of that, like I felt good.
So if I'm gonna miss anything
it's just gonna be the
people that I've met.
- [Mark] And what about working Figueroa?
- I'm not gonna miss
any of that (chuckling).
Fig no.
But it is something that I
do want people to understand
about this because they
look at these girls,
and they say, "well, if she
can make all this money"...
- [Mark] You're talking
about Figueroa now?
- [Ke] Yes.
- [Mark] Which is very
different from the Skid Row.
- [Ke] Yes. Very different
from Skid Row, right?
(Mark mumbles)
So they say, "they make
all this money" right?
But if we're living realistically, $500
it's $80 a night to stay in a
low budget motel, $80 a night.
So if you do the math and
times that times seven
that $500 that they make daily,
it's not really help.
And then let's face it
nine times out of 10
half the women out here
that are working the streets
are working with a man.
And this man don't give a
crap about where you sleep
or where you stay,
he just care about all the
money that you bring in.
So that he can look a certain type of way
or he can like....
- [Mark] And do you get
robbed some of the time?
- Yeah, like and half the girls get robbed
and it doesn't actually have to mean
that they're robbing you for your money.
They may be robbing you for the product
and you never see the money.
So it's like it's backstories to it,
and I wish instead of people judging
they would actually take the
time to actually figure out
who these women are and
why they do what they do
or what led them to do these things.
Because nine times out
of 10, at 18 years old
you have this savvy man
in your ear that's just giving
you all these sweet dreams
as a child, cause that's
what you are at the age of 18
you don't know anything.
This man tells you something
that sounds so good,
and yet he has on his
fancy clothes, his jewelry,
oh you're gonna be naive enough to believe
everything he's gonna tell you.
You don't know anything.
They start off as babies
and get brainwashed
into thinking that this
lifestyle is okay and it's not.
And I really pray that somebody's daughter
or someone's son has
mercy upon human nature
and decide that we gotta end it.
We have to end it.
It's more things into life
where we can fund our....
We can fund our habits,
whether it's clothes, jewelry,
you know, drugs, stuff like that.
There's other ways to
support these habits.
And we don't know these things
because we're only given
so much to work with.
And it's sad, but I'm glad
that my story ended up
shedding light because
it's a whole backside of it
that a lot people really don't understand.
Oh she pays this man, or she does this.
Some women actually get
turned out with a man
where they don't have
the ability to leave.
This man has burned
bridges with your family,
he has taken you out of state
or whatever the coincidence may be.
It's not always that the
woman wants to do this.
It's deeper than that.
And a lot of people,
like I said categorize us
as all these working women
instead of figuring out
what can I do to help you?
What is it that has you
so tied to this lifestyle?
I've seen several women die behind this.
Literally blocks away from where...
Not even blocks a block away
from where I used to stand.
Mass murderers like...
Stuff like this is real
and you wouldn't want your
daughter to go through it
so why would you sit back
and watch another one's
daughter go through it?
Or someone's sister, mother, it's painful.
And I really hope that one day
we all wake up and stop living
in so much hate and greed
cause that's what the world has come to.
It's so much evil, so
much hate, so much greed.
And it doesn't have to be.
- [Mark] You remind me
very much of another girl
that I interviewed on my channel Kelly,
who chose to walk away from
this lucrative lifestyle.
ended up on Skid Row
temporarily just like you did
just for a short time.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Didn't like it.
And you know, I helped
her with that situation
and my viewers did a donation campaign
and we helped her tremendously.
But it's a very remarkable
woman who has the strength
and the mental strength to
walk away from that life
and build another life from the ground up.
I mean, she got a nice
boost from that campaign,
but you're doing it on your own.
- Yes. And then see the
crazy thing about it is,
some of us are not fortunate enough
to have that mind frame.
- [Mark] Yeah. It takes a lot of strength.
- Exactly. I don't know.
I was raised off, it takes a village
to raise a child, right?
Right now it's like, where's the village?
It's like, we'd rather see
somebody go through something
that we've been through
and watch them fall
versus give them the lesson that we took
from the situation that we went through,
to help them from falling.
It's like, it's sad.
It's really sad.
Oh, well that's not my family member
or, oh that has nothing to do with me.
Oh, it's not my business.
What life have we become to?
To where the village
is not helping anymore.
It's sad, but I'm glad
because I still have a village
to help me raise my children.
- [Mark] Yeah, so you're
living with who now?
You're living with your mom?
- I'm living with my mother-in-law.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Yes. She opened her doors to
me to come and regain a part
of life that I was missing.
Which was my children
- [Mark] And you're
doing all right things?
- Yes.
- [Mark] There's no reason to kick you out
cause you're not working the streets
you're not doing drugs now.
- No, I left everything.
- [Mark] It's beautiful.
- Just for that moment to be with my kids.
To wake up with my kids in the morning
or to hear them playing around.
I left it all.
- [Mark] I hope you stay in this direction
and keep going darling.
- I do.
Plan to.
- [Mark] That's great.
- And I appreciate you
allowing me to share my story.
- [Mark] Did being able
to unload all the stuff
from the last talk help you?
- Yes, it did.
It really did.
- [Mark] I'm sure it
helped some of the viewers.
- It gave me an eye opener.
And like I said, I've been down here
since I've been stagnated down here.
Or let me say since I was,
because I'm no longer here
since I was stagnated here, I
was on a spiritual awakening.
So a lot of things that
I was sheltered from
I was allowed to see.
And I feel like he gave me a second chance
and I'm gonna do any
and everything possible
to make sure that I don't end up back here
or on Figueroa.
- [Mark] Yeah. They're both terrible.
- They're both terrible places.
- [Mark] In different ways but...
- In very different ways,
but the outcome and the ending
have very much similarities.
- [Mark] Yeah, they're very destructive.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Lifestyles.
- You get nothing out of it.
Fast money does not last long.
At all.
I did touch thousands, maybe even millions
I just sat in a hundred
thousand dollars cars
like I did been with people
where we didn't establish stuff.
It doesn't last long
- For a young woman to have
the mindset to walk away
from the temptation of all that.
Is what makes Kelly's and
your stories so remarkable.
Maybe people don't realize
how what you guys have done
is so unusual.
- It really is because
I mean, let's be honest.
Once you get bit by the hustle bug
it's kind of hard to walk away.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's like a drug, right?
- It is like an addiction,
cause it's like you always know you can go
and get some money fast.
- [Mark] Quick easy money.
- Exactly. So you may be at
home, oh my bills are due
I don't know what to do.
I do know what to do.
I do know what I can do.
It's not something that I wanna do,
but man it's all that I know,
right now I need the money.
It's very hard for a
person to fall back into.
- [Mark] I'm proud of you.
- Thank you, I appreciate it.
- [Mark] Okay, thank you so
much for coming in again.
- No problem.
Thank you for listening to my story.
- [Mark] Cool.
- [Mark] Is it nice to have mom back?
- Hmm?
- How do you feel that
I've been back home?
- Happy.
- Yeah?
- [Mark] Charlie is it
nice to have your mom back?
- You like having mommy back papa?
- He shy.
- [Mark] He shy.
- Very shy. (Ke chuckles)
- [Mark] Beautiful family.
- Thank you so much.
- [Mark] Thanks for coming in.
- [Ke] Thank you.